[Musique]
avec la tension qui monte entre la corée
du nord et les états unis
est ce que le canada est à l'abri on ne
vérifie
on va mettre une chose au clair dès le
départ il n'y a pas eu de menace directe
ou indirecte à l'endroit du canada on a
reçu un courriel de marie-france qui
nous demandent si les nord coréens vise
washington avec leurs missiles leurs
bombes nucléaires
est-ce que des risques pour nous c'est
vrai que quand on regarde un globe
terrestre le chemin le plus court entre
la corée du nord et washington en
passant au dessus du canada
sauf que les missiles qui ont été
testées jusqu'à maintenant par la corée
du nord se rendre aussi loin le plus
loin qu'un missile nord-coréen et
d'aller c'est à l'est du japon
autre chose importante à savoir c'est
que oui la corée du nord a fait des
tests de missiles oui elle a fait des
tests de bombe h
mais elle n'a pas fait de tirs de
missiles avec la bombe dessus
rien ne nous prouve en ce moment qu'elle
a réussi à miniaturiser la bombe ou
encore qu'elle est capable de faire
voyager un missile en ajoutant tout le
poids de la bombe le canada ne
participera pas au bouclier antimissile
en 2005 le canada a refusé de faire
partie du bouclier antimissile alors
puisqu'on n'a pas comme les américains
des engins qui sont prêts à être lancés
pour détruire un missile qui s'en vient
vers nous si jamais ça se produisait ce
sont les américains devraient prendre la
décision de neutraliser un missile en
direction du canada
si les états unis sont attaqués le
canada devra aller à sa défense parce
qu'il fait partie d'une organisation qui
s'appelle l'otan est une attaque contre
l'un de ces pays est considéré comme une
attaque contre tous si ce sont les états
unis qui attaquent en premier alors le
canada serait pas obligé d'intervenir si
vous voulez qu'on vérifie quelque chose
qui est venu